yeah i just posted on instagram uh some
different pictures that i took from our
sky camera
skycam shots and it is just not pretty
in any direction this morning but there
is relief on the way so that's the good
news is that those northerly winds are
already starting to take over and those
that's going to help push out all this
haze out of the air let's check the
latest pollen report there are some
changes now oak is showing up oak trees
moderate to even high counts of ragweed
oak and grasses air quality now it's not
healthy this morning for anyone with
respiratory illnesses
but it will eventually alleviate some of
that dust and haze as we get through the
day so at least moderate for the
afternoon but that dustin hayes will get
pushed to the south and back to the
desert areas as we get through the day
with the help of those winds and they're
starting to pick up north las vegas
nellis even harry reid international
winds are already 25 to near 30 miles an
hour and we're expecting those winds to
be about that strong from the north as
we've got a cold front moving through
temperatures are in the 70s to near 80
so it's been still quite warm overnight
and early this morning we hit 102
yesterday as we expected our first
triple digit day of the year 60s
mesquite indian springs perron 70s
boulder city searchlight laughlin but
look at the cool 30s ely tonepaw and
reno now they've had that cold front
pass through in northern nevada so it's
made quite a difference cedar city kind
of windy and chilly up there at 37 so it
will make a difference of our
temperatures 60 degrees up on the
mountain today sunny and cooler breezy
west northwest winds 25 30 miles an hour
and you know the lake is going to be
bumpy dicey probably get some white caps
at times today so please be careful but
look at the highs only in the mid 80s
today that cold front right now passing
through las vegas and into southern
clark county through the morning hours
so those breezy north winds will stick
around through the day even into tonight
and then calm down for your saturday so
it's going to be windier out at the lake
and along the colorado river valley we
have fire weather warnings until 8
o'clock
that's tonight so stronger winds and
staying very dry with these northwest
winds please stay hydrated it's going to
be a dry weekend too 83 today 83 that's
about a 20 degree drop from yesterday
now tomorrow when the winds calm down
that is going to be beautiful but look
at the mornings we're going to be back
into the 50s and low 60s through the
weekend so it's going to be cool for
mornings compared to what we've had
lately then back to 90s breezy again
sunday and then hotter triple digits
reappear later next week